to me what was most surprising about the
Democrat debate last night wasn't that
Elizabeth Warren came out punching
against Michael Bloomberg but how
unprepared he seemed from the get-go I'd
like to talk about who were running
against a billionaire who calls women
fat broads and horse-faced lesbians and
no I'm not talking about Donald Trump
I'm talking about Mayor Bloomberg well
Bloomberg's instinct then was to just
ignore Elizabeth Warren speak in general
terms and when all else failed just
recite his resume I'm a New Yorker I
know how to take on an arrogant con man
like Donald Trump that comes from New
York I'm a mayor was a mayor I know how
to run a complicated city the biggest
most diverse city in this country
although Warren was circling him like a
turkey vulture over a wounded fawn he
has gotten some number of women dozens
who knows to sign non-disclosure
agreements both for sexual harassment
and for gender discrimination in the
workplace so mr. mayor are you willing
to release all of those women from those
non-disclosure agreements so we can hear
their side of the story
well you would think with all that dough
he shelled out for campaign talent that
Bloomberg would be ready with a sharp
response to those obvious point she was
gonna raise right well none of them
accused me of doing anything other than
maybe they didn't and when you say they
signed them and they wanted them if they
wish now to speak out and tell their
side of the story about what it is they
allege that's now okay with you they
wanted to keep it quiet for everybody's
interest bound by being muzzled by you
they were made
consensually
and they have every right to expect that
they will stay boy zero emotion that
weird got zero connection and in the end
zero credibility on stage he has neither
the raw political skill or the raw
instinct of Trump or Bernie for that
matter now Bernie I have to give him
credit he knows his base and his base
wants massive wealth redistribution we
have a grotesque and immoral
distribution of wealth in income Mike
Bloomberg owns more wealth than the
bottom a hundred and twenty five million
Americans that's wrong that's immoral
Mayor Bloomberg should you exist all I
know is I've been very lucky made a lot
of money and I'm giving it all away to
make this country better and the good
chunk of it goes to the Democratic Party
as well
[Applause]
as if in an obscene amount of should you
have earned that much money yes can you
believe that question first of all
should you have earned that what well
Bloomberg's best effort I think at
defending capitalism actually came later
in the debate when Bernie went in for
the kill Bloomberg wasn't you who made
all that money maybe your workers played
some role in that as well workers to be
able to sit on corporate boards as well
so they can support senator Sanders is
proposing absolutely not I can't think
of a ways that would make it easier for
Donald Trump to get re-elected and
listening to this conversation the
country's tried that was called
communism and it just didn't work well
neither did your performance frankly it
was too little too late Bloomberg has
gone through life I think thinking that
he who pays the piper calls the tune
that rich folks have real power and the
rest of us they just have to do what the
rich people say but both Trump and
Bernie they understand power better than
Bloomberg does they know that you can
also achieve power by having a strong
message and taking that message right to
the voters but for years Bloomberg
ignored the many signs that GOP voters
were fed up with the type of people who
were in our party and they wanted to go
in a more populist direction and of
course the populist eventually took over
the Republican Party and then Bloomberg
became a Democrat but meanwhile the left
has spent decades teaching folks that
America is an evil country that
capitalism is evil that rich people like
Bloomberg are evil even if he gives away
his money and that we will all die soon
due to an mediate climate emergency so
now Bloomberg finds himself trapped he's
trapped in a part
virtually everyone who actually cares
about the issues wants to nominate
socialists even if that risks losing it
all to Trump so what's happening to
Bloomberg should be a list of anyone who
cares about capitalism if the voters
don't trust the free-market system
they'll try to abolish it and slit
campaigns and a lot of money that you
spend on consultants won't be sufficient
to change their minds last night's
debate showed that Trump is the last
best hope for capitalism because he
supports a market system but also
understands the importance of making
sure that American workers benefit from
that system but it's too late for
someone like Bloomberg to parachute in
and tell everyone sit down and shut up
let me run the show and that's the angle